hello believe nation I served the mentum
e-series with the goal to hang around
people who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully some of their mindsets way
of thinking values seep in to us to help
us become the best version of ourselves
so today we've compiled a list of all of
the best clips from Gary Vaynerchuk in
2016 of his best motivation to help you
get ready for an amazing 2017 and as
always as Gary's talking if you said
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
could be inspired as well enjoy
you
it breaks my heart my friends like live
for Friday night like they know there
was like Monday morning is the worst
it's just absolute huge percentage of
one's life I can't wrap my head around
with the internet this is not your
grandpappy's life we have the Internet
you can make [ __ ] happen you can build
businesses or side hustles I just don't
understand why people relegate into
losing mentality and just thinking they
can't you can't because you want to be
on the bowling team or softball and play
video games that's why you can there's
plenty of time gets done the level of
complaining is unacceptable look what if
I told you this was the last Monday
morning of your life where do I go do
you die this week would you complain
about your crap job or that test you
don't want to think I doubt it
you go much higher level thinking well
that's really what it takes it takes
understanding that if you're not pumped
right out if you're grunting what you're
about to do it here if you're not
looking forward please recognize the
world we're living in we're living in a
world where so much more opportunity
this internet thing created many more
opportunity for all of us way more I
know you only got even be alive like
your mom and dad could have had sex like
three minutes later and you weren't even
exist and you're complaining you could
have ended up being a plus 3 I just go
get the mentality of being head down sad
on a Monday morning I'm going to make
Monday morning my [ __ ] I'm going to
make things Saturday Monday morning
that's what I want to do every morning
and that's what I want from you please
take a step back and think about how
awesome it actually is and then
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way if you are
lucky enough to be born during this era
if you're not great at it or you love it
more than life should you go after it
the and we the interest yes the problem
is
please also recognize you're probably
not going to get rich like if you love
basketball more than life it's just when
you always loved you might just make
forty nine thousand dollars a year being
a basketball coach and having a lot of
time on your hand to play basketball
it's just you gotta understand
you can't have everything all the time
always it's just life I think happiness
trumps everything easy for me to say
because it really works out for me
because happiness coincides with
financial upside I have friends who make
seventy four thousand dollars a year
that are just happier people than
friends that are making eighteen million
a year that are not you've got to do you
but please don't let the entrepreneurial
society don't let me don't let your
parents push you into what success is
it's different for all of us but and
this is the big but you got to be
self-aware about it I just stay in my
lane
like this is back to self-awareness I
stay in my lane
I'm a Salesman I'm a business builder
I've done in my whole life I was an F
student at 13 and 14 my friend's parents
told my friends not to hang out with me
because I was a loser I'm more
successful than my entire graduating
class combined life like this is because
the market doesn't understand that
people don't get it you have to double
down on your strengths and you have to
punch your reconsent in America there's
billions of dollars made I'm telling you
how to fix the things that you're not
good at it's a huge mistake you need to
figure out who you are and go all-in
that's what I did and so when you talk
about business or marketing when you
talk about the New York Jets and when
you talk about wine I've got nothing but
providing everything out patients see me
sitting around dinner tables right now
talking about politics the level of
humility and the level of listening you
wouldn't expect for me because that
grausen used to consuming me I'm loud
and proud because I only stay in my lane
pay very close attention I've got nine
years of content on the internet now
maybe a little bit more I've stayed very
very very narrow so nice lucky
[Music]
the reason I've been able is kind of
growth is my narrow things its consumer
behavior which I can deploy against
anything so my narrow thing happens to
be quite wide which allows you to play
lovely be good investor allows you to on
businesses it allows you to do a
personal Britax it allows you to do
things but I don't believe in that and
it was originally stated in here for
public able other a is this visionary
past screw be really pretty in over my
[Music]
party box by the way by the way that's
the senior two firms when you miss firm
that's what humans are good at we all
fail we've all failed like third by I
like the herons haven't been killed my
child and those people have their
children died but could you imagine like
the idea comes like listen unfortunately
or fortunately depends on how one wants
to look at it I'm a pretty optimistic
guy I lost three of my four grandparents
before I was really before I knew them
before I was born and one very early on
like so you know it's easy for me to be
happy I like in the right order the
health and well-being of my family and
there's nothing even remotely close to
that not even not even remotely people
have gotten three much for this is why
I'm trying to recall our grandparents
and our great-grandparents people were
persecuted and kill like I just will not
have real headaches you know I don't
know why I have this highly emotional
and then completely unemotional part of
me but I mix them together to create the
balance and that's what works for me so
a horse there's nothing that I couldn't
get upfront like every other human ever
besides somebody who now lives in some
weird cave that we don't know about you
know what I mean we are sluggish
we're really wrong we're just being sold
that we're not because there's a lot of
money a lot of money in telling us that
were not pretty enough thin enough smart
enough good enough that I want to tell
you you're bad condition we're going to
make less money this year at 100 million
that we made last year at 67 neck I
don't mean percentage neck meaning
they're in trouble then I see it which
means I over invested more people more
capabilities because I'm gonna take the
whole pie so you know any like I'm not
worried about how much cash I'm going to
take home in 2016 because I can take a
lot more in 2020 then I you know much
more fun to take home 44 million in 2020
s and 3 million in 2017 18 and 19
instead of 4 million in 28 people which
99% of the market is shorter and the 1%
that isn't and has the talent wins every
time
which makes no sense because unless
you're going to die
you should only play long term there was
a stat that some dude in Mexico City
said one of these like futuristic type
of characters I'm sure he's smart I have
no idea who so I just but he was right
before me as I was miked up and he says
it's been scientifically proven so I
don't know if it has or not because I've
learned to take that with a grain of
salt but that 85% of what humans make
decisions about is irrational
and that's spoke to me because a I think
it's higher and B it's why I think all
my success is happening I am stunningly
the most rational and the most practical
of all yet I don't see them
and when he said in like right that's
why because the rest of the market is
irrational I'm desperate for people to
start defining their hopes and dreams
and wants and needs on their terms not
on what I say I don't care if you want
to hustle 18 hours a day I really no I
really really don't I don't care if you
want to buy the New York Jets I don't
care what you want or need you need to
care about what you wanted you can't
worry about what I'm saying you can't
worry about whatever your flavor of the
month is right maybe on this wave of the
month right now maybe maybe maybe a
consistent flavor of the life is your
mom's point of view is your older
brother who's got exactly what she wants
you to be a lawyer but you don't want to
be a lawyer you want to be a happy heart
if you want to you want to take a chance
to be an entrepreneur or the reverse or
the reverse I know it reaches and love
doggin worship more than me but I think
all the time talking about like self
awareness are you one this is a golden
in Europe for entrepreneurship people
ask me for selfies this will go away it
may not always win but it's going to go
away like you know it's entrepreneurship
like a rap artist like a baseball player
like the heavyweights nobody cares who
the heavyweight champion of the world is
right now
look at Aaron I have been shorter did in
nineteen thirty nine and nineteen
you know 54 for a heavyweight champ or
who you know they change they change and
it will always change and it will
continuously change and right now
entrepreneurship is in this pedestal as
having its moment and what a beautiful
of is that you watch my
in my Instagram case and what I want to
clarify for everybody is I hope you
understand I am NOT giving advice to
everybody the only place I'd like to
gift everybody is to find what your
North Star is to understand yourself
understand what your work-life balance
ambitions are how much what your
financial ambitions are when your life
challenges are the problems that you
want to try to solve ensure as we all do
as humans trying to climb those
different mountains in our life what we
can take that is all that matters
don't you know I don't think they leave
you or for all these videos for you to
be like me I don't think anybody should
be like me boil or enormous amounts of
pressures and sacrifices that I
recognize you're just not healthy or
valuable to anybody else but it's also
not healthy or valuable to me to do some
of the things that you want me to do
like it's not fun for me to work 9:00 to
5:00 like I will break I will be equally
devastated as you would be to work till
midnight every day and so we just need a
call to action for everybody recognize
we have to stop judging everything I'm
not judging
I'm creating content for you to use of
the barometer to try to figure out what
you like and what you don't like I'm
trying to like value my words my actions
and my content to bring the people to
empathize and that's really that's the
clarification like I don't want people
to to be likely I don't want people to
think I love people to do themself and
they just have to start with
understanding themselves and not trying
to be like me of this moment or that
person in Mexico miss that person next
moment the people that most literally
chew with themselves and figure
themselves there's a reason that sec
sighs and gals like me continue to have
audiences because people want to be
motivated to go and do things or they
want to learn tactics to go and do
things but it's whether I'm giving you
tactical advice like filters on snapchat
or Facebook ads or Instagram story
collaboration or I'm motivating you
through my words they I communicate that
way for for my actions seeing this wake
up to five courses it's everybody who's
watching this actually did something
about it
and then went on the course of their
version of it and then they wouldn't be
watching this and I genuinely know at
the bottom of my heart out of all the
people that want to build audiences that
I'm the complete opposite of almost all
of them because 99% of people that
produce content like this that are out
there like I am the business of being
that is what they are I have businesses
I have wine library invader mean I don't
need your 14 bucks for my book or to be
in my course or this amount so I don't
need to monetize you so I then genuinely
want you to never watch me again the
problem is every time you guys are
posting human times I see on my on my
Instagram oh I needed this today and you
know any time by steppers and nine
months later still hanging around if you
needed it then take it and do something
about it
the reason there's gonna be a billion
motivational views today on YouTube is
that people love the feeling of being
motivated they don't like putting in the
work and do something about the feeling
I think the biggest obstacle to success
is a lack of optimism I think the world
like lacks optimism I think you know
everyone's like your energy your energy
I've come to realize it's just optimism
just happy - positive
what it is like whatever chemicals are
in my body they just allow me to see the
bright side like and I just don't think
I realized how few people have that like
nope
very few people have it as black and
white hundred zero like I just think
everything's good but like it doesn't
come naturally a lot of people I think I
think that's like you know if I was able
to say I'm lucky about something forget
about the business result its lucky that
that optimism comes naturally to me like
I'm just optimistic like I just think
that so much works for me because I
refuse to accept the negative like I you
know and I don't think I hear what
people say it's you know it's an option
or it's a choice I agree with you Susan
I don't think it comes natural to
everybody I think we are just starting
on the early stages of a really looking
at mental health the brain meditation
what I want to do with my attention is
allow the 2,000 of you to cut tens of
thousands of you to take it I want to
hand you my optimism my happiness my my
view of the world my opportunities that
I see in the light space and I want to
give it to you for free and then I want
you to win how do you stay driven I'm
gonna ask you questions how don't you
stay driven will let me get this right
you won the lotto of the universe which
is you're a human being on earth you I'm
just going to say this I mean I don't
think people think about this you won
the lotto you in the universe you're not
some weird specimen in Mars that does
nothing you're not you know a bird you
know you're not a sunflower like you're
a human being on earth you won the
ultimate ultimate lottery and you're not
driven and you're not fired up and
you're not going for it and you're
willing to sit like a lump and just wait
till you die you suck
like I don't know you suck like I how do
I stay driven because I couldn't even
comprehend the alternative the biggest
poison in us is regret it's poison and I
push so hard so hard and we'll through
my vehicle which is a meditation which
isn't health and wellness which is a
nonprofit my vehicles business I can't
help it it's what I love we love
building businesses I love competing you
want to beat you I love that game but
through that vehicle I will always push
a lack of regret and awareness how good
it really is you're more than welcome to
tell me about how bad it is or why you
can't because for what but it's just not
true because if anybody ever did it and
you can do stop making excuses
stop complaining nobody's listening
they made me pretend they're listening
the market doesn't care when you need to
do is make one person happy you then you
can make everybody else happy you know
why I like making people happy as I'm
already happy and so I implore you to
take this last little rant and really
look at your face and understand are you
doing the things that are putting you in
a position to succeed not just in a
business world but in life because it's
super important biggest boy when you're
happy in life just business control and
so I'm just trying to figure it out and
I've been trying to figure it out in
front of you for the last seven eight
years trying to figure out the unlocks
each you IQ self-awareness hustle I
don't know what they are you know why
three hundred thirty different online
it's all good all of them they're all
tried-and-true and one might hit you
yeah it was hard work because I'm
actually lazy a talk of the game but I'm
poor or it might be something else but
one so this being sudden remember one
life one life my friends one time and
honestly I'll leave you with this
because a lot of you needed how you make
your money is more important than how
much you make thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
are you inspired are you motivated what
was your favorite message and what would
did you learn most that you're going to
apply immediately to you in life or your
business after watching this video leave
it in the comments below and I'm going
to join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to stay Czar
Bonilla thank you so much for picking up
a cup of my book your one word and
posting that awesome picture on Twitter
I really really really really appreciate
it so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love please